تتكون مدينة R التركية من تلال
Emerald Green Hills
والمنازل الخشبية التقليدية ولكن ما يضيف حقًا إلى
المناظر الخلابة للمدينة هو
المساحة الشاسعة من
مزارع الشاي لذلك أه حدث في هذه
الأداة الصغيرة هنا لا أعرف
بالضبط ما هي  أو ما يسمى
ولكنه يستخدم لنقل الشاي
وأحيانًا الأشخاص حول المزرعة،
لذلك هذا عندما تبدأ في التشكيك في
اختيارك المهني. أنا أحب الشاي، هل أحب
الشاي، هذا هو ما
تعرفت عليه هنا من هاتي تشاي التي
كانت تقطف الشاي  منذ أن
كان عمرها 10 سنوات، كانت
[موسيقى]
سريعة جدًا والتضاريس ليست
سهلة التنقل، فهي شديدة الانحدار حقًا.
تبدأ هاتي في قطف أوراق الشاي في
حوالي الساعة 7:00 صباحًا كل صباح
وتستمر حتى الساعة 500 مساءً.  كل يوم
تحصد حوالي 300
[موسيقى]
كجم، ويشارك هذا العمل الآلاف من
السكان هنا في ريز الذين يعتمدون على
اقتصاد الشاي المزدهر في تركيا، حتى أن البعض
يقدر أن تركيا تستهلك شايًا
للفرد أكثر من أي دولة أخرى في
العالم، وأعتقد أنه  أي
ما يعادل كل شخص في
تركيا. 85 مليون شخص يشربون أربعة
أكواب من الشاي كل يوم.
[موسيقى]
سوف تجد أوراق الشاي المقطوفة حديثًا
طريقها إلى أيدي
شركات المعالجة المختلفة، من بينها
لازيكا، مصنع بوتيك معروف
بتعاونه مع  المزارعون أصحاب الحيازات الصغيرة
مثل hatti J مرحبًا
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا، هذا يترك في الأساس انتظر
هناك لمدة 24 ساعة ثم جفف بشكل طبيعي
إيمرا يحث أحد المالكين على أن
شرب الشاي أو الشاي كما يطلق عليه هنا
يرتبط ارتباطًا وثيقًا بالثقافة التركية
ويعني الصداقة في بعض الأحيان.  يعني
الحب في بعض الأحيان يكرهك، تعرف إذا كنت تريد
القتال مع شخص ما، تناول الشاي
لكل الأسباب، أعني مناقشة
شيء ما، قم بالمناقشة عندما تشعر
بالأسف، عندما تشعر بالأسف،
تناول الشاي، عندما تكون سعيدًا، تناول
الشاي  في كل اه كل عاطفة
نتناول الشاي، إنه يتعلق بالحياة
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
تنتج تركيا حوالي 10% من
الشاي في العالم وفقًا لبعض التقديرات
وغالبية ذلك
الشاي الأسود لازيكا تبتعد ببطء عن
هذا التقليد و  بعد التعمق في
إنتاج الشاي الأخضر والأبيض العضوي، بعد
يوم من العمل في قطف وتجفيف الشاي،
يقول إيموري إنه لم
يتبق سوى شيء واحد للقيام به الآن، إنه وقت هورون،
ما هو هورون هورون هو رقصة فولكلورية
لتلك المنطقة، البحر الأسود، أعني أه
فقط  لا تتردد وحاول الانضمام إليهم،
إنه أمر سهل، إنه تحرك سهل ولكنه
تقليدي للغاية ولكنك ستعرض لي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق] [
موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لي غو
قريبًا